[Music]  the points what they've been telling me  in the bathroom I need someone to talk  to  I've been hearing that and I hear what  they say my name they're trying to trust  me I say my name Tiffany is over here  playing and talking to spirits I don't  know if this is some weird strategy but  either way she's gotta go really what is  she doing so being an actress Oh hands  down you don't have someone like so much  they believe they lie I think she  started really believe she's a medium at  this point she reminds me of Whoopi  Goldberg and ghost  Trina you have connections with those  mediums and psychics and all that they  get rid of them she doesn't do that  she's like they want to be related this  one wants you to take them shopping what  you talking about Drita has to leave so  if I have to use the fear of the spirits  in this house to help me pick a rock you  better believe I'm gonna use the spirits  to my advantage  [Music]  you